vielen dank für die für die einladung
was ich auch sagen muss dass dieser
titel den sie hier sehen nicht mehr ganz
in dem entspricht was ich ihnen
vortragen möchte es wird weiterhin um
den vergleich des menschen und der tiere
gehen
es wird aber weniger um entstehung von
normativität gehen als zunächst darum
was überhaupt unter normativität
verstanden werden kann
ich werde verschiedene begriffe der
normativität zu unterscheiden versuchen
und dabei wird es nicht nur um normative
und nicht normative ordnungen der
kooperation gehen sondern auch um andere
formen der normativität weil eben diese
anderen formen der normativität in der
diskussion um den lebensformen begriff
in der letzten zeit eine große rolle
spielen
deswegen werde ich auch am anfang mit
dem begriff der lebensform beginnen
es werde über arten und lebensformen
ihnen etwas sagen dann werde ich über
drei komplexe in denen von normativität
die rolle die rede ist sprechen
normativität und lebensform normativität
und lebendigkeit und normativität und
durch human komplex was sie darunter
verstehen können werde ich ihnen
erläutern
und am ende wird es abschließend über
den menschen den begriff des menschen
zwischen einem art und lebensform
begriff gehen
ich fange also an mit harten und
lebensformen von lebensformen das haben
wir schon gehört ist in den letzten
jahren in der ethik anthropologie und
politischen philosophie viel die rede
der begriff erscheint prominent in den
schriften der sogenannten neo
aristotelischen philosophen verlange
marco thompson oder resident haus
sie haben ein spezielles verständnis des
begriffs das nicht dem in der biologie
etablierten begriff entspricht
sie verwenden den ausdruck um das
verhältnis eines individuums zu seiner
artspezifischen natur zu bezeichnen
sie haben ein theologisches verständnis
dieses verhältnisses insofern sie mit
der zuschreibung eine lebensform die
tendenz zur verwirklichung dieser art
spezifischen natur verbunden sehen für
diese autoren transportierte begriff der
lebensform daher normative implikationen
darauf werde ich im nächsten abschnitt
näher eingehen hier will ich zunächst
nur auf die in meinen augen sehr
problematischen gleich setzungen der
begriffe lebensform und art bei diesen
autoren hinweis diese gleichsetzung
findet sich konzentriert ausgedrückt im
index von philipp buchner bündnis im
index wo es heißt live for species also
will man wissen was wird unter live vorm
versteht wird man of species verwiesen
und die äquivalenz der beiden begriffe
befindet sich gleichermaßen michael
thompson als live action von 2008 er
will die beiden begriffe mehr oder
weniger äquivalent verwenden wie er
schreibt für das biologische verständnis
der begriffe ist diese behauptete
äquivalenz allerdings vollkommen
irreführend irreführend ist sie weil art
biologisch in der regel als geologisches
konzept verstanden wird lebensformen
dagegen typologische zuerst den begriff
der art biologische arten sind
historische entitäten spätestens seit
ende des 17
in ihrem netz seit john wray wird der
biologische art begriff über den
reproduktions zusammenhang von
individuen definiert gemeinsame
abstammung die individuen von einem
vorfahren ist bei ray das kriterium der
art zugehörig
und daran folgen ihm die mehrzahl der
biologen seit dem 18 jahrhundert hier
nur einige das ist ray der kurz grüßt
hier einige beispiele der biologen die
grey folgen
george buffet ist im zweiten band seiner
vorgeschichte von 17 49 der ansicht man
könne das zur gleichen art rechnen was
sich über das mittel der paarung
fortpflanzt und die ähnlichkeit der art
erhält ernstmeier definiert in dem von
ihm so genannten biologischen art
begriff 942 als gruppen arten als
gruppen von tatsächlich oder
potenziellen sich kreuzenden
populationen die hinsichtlich ihrer
fortpflanzung von anderen solchen
gruppen getrennt sind
rainer willmann sie taten als
evolutionäre abschnitte des
evolutionären baums nämlich solche die
zwischen zwei verzweigungen des baums
zwei spezies ionen liegen oder zwischen
einer spezies ion und dem zeitpunkt
ihres nachkommen losen aussterbens und
schließlich definiert jerkins den wir
auch die beste wissenschaftliche
torische darstellung des biologischen
passes verdanken im jahr 2003 atem als
stammes linien von organismen images
organismus die über gemeinsame merkmale
verfügen die sie von anderen solchen
stammes linien getrennt halten
entscheidend ist dabei dass wir
besonders in der letzten definition
deutlich dass das kriterium der art
zugehörigkeit die gemeinsame abstimmung
ist die zwar auf gemeinsamen merkmalen
beruht es sind aber nicht die
gemeinsamen merkmale als solche die über
die art zugehörigkeit entscheiden
sondern allein die merkmale insofern sie
eine folge der gemeinsamen abstammung
sind und eine fortsetzung der art in der
zukunft durch gemeinsame fortpflanzung
bedingen arten sind also durch eine
relationale kriterium derart
zugehörigkeit definiert es gibt keine
intrinsischen oder wie es auch häufig
heißt keine essentiellen merkmale eines
organismus die ihn als mitglied einer
art ausweisen
eine art kann alle ihre merkmale
verändern
und doch die gleiche art bleiben wenn
sie nur die gemeinsame
fortpflanzungsfähigkeit bewahrt
jetzt kommt also auf diese art trades
der keeper des denk von avenches bei
wilkens an wenn die rotkehlchen ihrer
zukünftigen evolution in ihre
zukünftigen revolution almeria
allmählich ihre rote kelle verlieren
würden aber trotzdem ihren
fortpflanzungs zusammenhang behalten
würden dann würden sie trotzdem den
status einer gemeinsamen art bewahren es
kommt also hier auf die relationalen
eigenschaften hat über die art
zugehörigkeit entscheiden die
eigenschaften die ein individuum mit
anderen teilt nicht die eigenschaften
die es für sich hat biologische arten
sind damit keine netze karins im sinne
von chemischen elementen die über ihre
intrinsischen eigenschaften definiert
sind sondern sie sind historische
entitäten grafisch darstellbar sind sie
daher als ausschnitte des stammbaums des
lebens hier eine solche darstellung von
einem bekannten biologen willi hennig in
der deutlich wird dass art unterschiede
historisch entstehen durch barrieren in
reproduktions beziehungen
es sind eben relationen paarungen die
diese differenzen begründen und
stabilisieren
das hierarchische in taktische system
der biologischen taxonomie ist so gebaut
dass ist diese sukzession von philo
genetischen spaltung ereignissen
abbilden soll
hier in einer anderen darstellung herr
nix die uns vertrauten hierarchischen
ebenen der biologischen taxonomie von
arten familien ordnungen und klassen
bilden also ineinander ineinander
gestapelte mengen von individuen die
durch die sukzessiven spaltung
ereignisse von stammes linien im laufe
der evolution entstanden sind eine
konsequenz aus dieser genealogische
historisch basierten begriffsbildung in
der biologischen taxonomie
einschließlich des begriffs ist wie
gesagt dass individuen keine
intrinsischen oder wesentlichen merkmale
haben die sie als angehörige einer art
aus weingarten seit den siebziger jahren
haben einflussreiche philosophen der
biologie daraus den schluss gezogen dass
es nicht so etwas gibt wie die essenz
oder das wesen einer art damit schreibt
978 species
es ist oracle entertain-paket jeder
organismus bildung in der partie chile
species die cosplayer part of the logic
um nächstes dick cheney said trades
species in essens in das sense and there
is no such thing as human nature und bei
michael kissel in heißt es 20 jahre
später bot klassischen teacher's award
teenage riot ersatztermin ages es gibt
es tische wird der ausdruck mensch als
bezeichnung für eine biologische art
verstanden dann kann es ebenso wenig wie
für jede andere biologische art auch
keine entrinnen sicher eigenschaft für
die art des menschen geben die diese art
definieren würde es kann nach hall zwar
merken alle geben die zurzeit nur
mitgliedern der art homo sapiens zu
kommen dies wäre aber ein bloß
kontingentes faktum zu einem zeitpunkt
der evolution als historische einheit
könnten sich die merkmale von menschen
ändern ohne dass diese einer anderen art
zu gerechnet werden müssten
die annahme einer zeitlich konstanten
menschlichen natur ist ein aberglaube
ist barcelona ist das gleiche gilt für
alle anderen biologischen art
bezeichnungen
es gibt auch keine natur der kohlmeise
des rotkehlchens wenn diese namen als
bezeichnungen für biologische arten
verwendet werden
aber der ausdruck mensch muss natürlich
nicht im sinne eines biologischen art
begriffs verstanden werden und der
begriff der lebensform weist eine
möglichkeit wie von menschen gesprochen
werden kann ohne die vorstellung von
einer menschlichen natur ganz zu
verlieren und damit komme ich eben zu
diesem grunde lebensformen lebens
lebensform ist ein ausdruck der in
biologischer bedeutung seit langem und
verwendung ist mindestens so lange wie
es die biologie gibt mindestens seit 200
jahren in technologischer verwendung
erscheint er seit ende des 19
jahrhunderts eingeführt wurde er in
technologischer bedeutung im rahmen der
botanik der vegetation kunde hier sehen
sie einige definitionen des begriffs
helmut ganz definierten 118 als zur
selben lebensformen gehören alle
diejenigen einzel formen sei es nun
arten oder nur bestimmte generationen
oder entwicklungsstadien von solchen die
am selben lebensraum
die an denselben lebensraum angepasst
sind karl-friedrich 230 zur gleichen
lebensformen gehören diejenigen wesen
arten generationen oder stadien die in
ähnlichem habitat in ähnlicher weise
leben die kaulquappe gehört vergleichen
lebensformen wie die meisten fische der
frosch zu einer anderen wilhelm kuhnert
153 ein individuum kann merkmale zwei
recht verschiedene lebensformen tragen
die je nach dem augenblicklichen
aufenthalt entsprechend zur geltung
kommen inzwischen trägt eine heuschrecke
fliegen schwimmen und springend es geht
also bei lebensformen in diesem
verständnis nicht um genealogische
beziehungen sondern um anpassungs
komplex um ähnlichkeiten in formen und
lebensweisen ein individuum kann dabei
durchaus zu verschiedenen lebensformen
gerechnet werden zum beispiel ein
kormoran kann je nach aktivität in die
gruppe der in der luft liegenden auf dem
land sitzenden im wasser schwimmenden
oder tauchenden lebewesen geordnet
werden
die gleiche lebensform kann in
unterschiedlichen verwandtschaft gruppen
erscheinen hier sehen sie eine bekannte
übersicht in der für springen der
pflanzenfresser wie den hasen für
unterirdisch graben die tiere wie den
maulwurf für fliegende laufvögel wie den
strauß oder laufende raubtiere wie den
löwen vertreter aus verschiedenen
kontinenten zusammen gestellt sind
gleiche lebensformen entstehen durch
evolutionäre konvergenz also durch
evolutionäre veränderungen in den
unterschiedlichen verwandtschaft kreisen
die als anpassungen an ähnliche
umweltbedingungen zu erklären sind wie
etwa die wiederholte entstehung der
spindel form bei unter wasser
schwimmenden profitieren klassifiziert
werden lebensformen seit den dreißiger
jahren in sehr einfache kategorien so
von carl-friedrich 19 30 auf der
grundlage des aufenthaltsorts von
lebewesen unterscheidet ortsgebundene
wesen von solchen die zum ortswechsel
fähig sind und innerhalb der letzteren
die bewohner flüssiger oder halb
schlüssiger medien die bewohner fester
medien und luft bewohner das
umfassendste system eine ordnung von
lebensformen geht auf den theologen hans
wilhelm köpfe zurück der anfang der 70er
jahre eine große zweibändige monografie
zu den lebensformen verfasst hat
die lebensformen grundlage zu einer
universell gültigen biologischen theorie
so hat er das buch genannt
köppen köpke gliedert die lebensformen
nach organischen grundfunktionen und
unterscheidet diese sechs lebensweise
typen des substanz erwerbs da geht's
auch ernährung der locomotion also
fortbewegung der resistenz das sind
schutzstrategien der sozialität also
formen der vergesellschaftung von tieren
der brut fürsorge und der sexualität mit
jeweils diversen lebensform typen als
untergruppe für jeden der großen
biologischen funktion komplexe lassen
sich mit köpfe also lebensformen typen
bestimmen die sich gegenwärtig
überkreuzen jedes lebewesen gehört damit
gleichzeitig und je nach momentaner
aktivität unterschiedlichen lebensformen
achten für kötter ist die lebensformen
kunde auch insofern von theoretischer
bedeutung als er mit ihr die möglichkeit
gegeben sieht die biologie nicht nur als
eine historische sondern auch als eine
gesetzes wissenschaft aufzufassen
zu diesem zweck stellt er die von ihm so
genannten nachdem homologen biologie der
analogien biologie gegenüber zur
homologen biologie gehören die
biologische systematik philologie und
biogeographie also alle zweige der
biologie die sich um eine rekonstruktion
der geschichte des lebens im laufe der
zeit bemühen zur analogen geologie
rechnet köpke dagegen diejenigen zweige
der biologie in denen es um gesetze geht
die über verschiedene verwandtschaft
kreise hinweg gültigkeit haben
dazu rechnet er die genetik physiologie
und ökologie und eben auch die
lebensformen konnte mit den begriffen
art und form markiert letztlich köpkes
grafik auch so darstellen
biologische art begriffe beziehen sich
auf historisch genealogische
zusammenhänge form begriffe auch für
allgemeine rungen und gesetze unabhängig
von historischen entstehungs
zusammenhängen
als ergebnis dieses ersten langen
abschnitt meines vortrags möchte ich
daher festhalten lebensformen taten sind
etwas sehr unterschiedlich ist und ich
komme zum zweiten abschnitt in dem es um
normativität um lebensform gehen wird
für die auffassung dass mit der
zuordnung eines lebewesens zu einer
lebensform normative implikationen
verbunden sind plädiert bekanntlich
marke thompson in seinem buch life and
action mit der erkenntnis dass ein
lebewesen einer lebensform angehört sind
nach thomson eine besondere form von
urteilen verbunden naturhistorische
urteile wie er sie nennt
wenn etwa wenn etwas eine eichel genannt
wird dann liegt in diesem urteil nicht
nur die beschreibung eines individuellen
dinges sondern dieses werde gleichzeitig
in einen weiteren kontext eingebettet
dieser kontext weise über das individuum
hinaus auf das typische art dass
thompson seine lebensformen nennt jede
lebensbeschreibung ist wie thompson auch
eine lebensform darstellung und insofern
mit der klassifikation eines lebewesens
in eine typologische ordnung verbunden
die identifikation eines tieres als rot
luxus rufus schließt ein dass dieses
tier vierbeiner hat bzw vierbeiner haben
soll
denn die dies ist der standard für einen
rot los diese generelle form der art
brut lux ist die form oder wie sie das
der rödl sagt das maß für jeden
individuellen roth lux es soll form und
mars sein selbst wenn sie von der
mehrzahl der inszenierungen der form
nicht erreicht wird
mit der identifizierung von etwas als
eichel ist die lebensform aussage
verbunden dass daraus einmal eine eiche
werden soll
auch wenn die meisten eicheln dieses
ziel nicht erreichen thompson sieht mit
lebensformen urteilen daher eine
unmittelbar und mittelbar eine
normativität verbunden
er entwickelt diese normativität
ausgehend von individuellen defekten in
denen das was sein soll gerade nicht
realisiert ist etwas einem etwa einen
rot lux mit nur drei beinen oder eine
eiche die sich nicht so entwickelt also
gut im hintergrund entwickelt er seine
normativität für diesen entwicklung
dieser defekte er schreibt legend of
natural defekte explained machten die
sensation perfekt interview in ritchies
beyond the sword epi quali tobi facts
nämlich fraktion auch bekannt aus pieces
of life for what they want to be in die
division retail sales form
das sollen das für das individuum
besteht soll hier also an der
beschreibung der form hängen die
zuordnung zu einer lebensform liefert
quasi die brücke über die sein sollen
schlucht hinweg oder wie thompson 2004
ist ausdruck zu bringen die virtuell an
der life forestry mainz zsl time to
bring it an der certain sword of
standard kritisch ist gegen diese
vorstellung eines standards einer norm
der normalität eine lebensform die
normative konsequenzen haben soll
also eine normalität mit normativen
konsequenzen gewarnt worden dass sie mit
dem modernen biologischen art begriff
nicht vereinbar sei
biologische arten sind darauf haben
unter anderem ursula wolf und anton leiß
verwiesen im rahmen des der darwinschen
evolutionstheorie nicht mehr
typologische zu verstehen
ausgerichtet an einer norm sondern als
populationen für die variation
essentiell ist innerhalb des
evolutionstheorie tisch genealogische
bestimmten art begriffs gibt es keinen
standard der als norm fungieren könnte
ich denke diese kritiker haben recht
soweit es um den biologischen art
begriff geht
thompson könnte seine position nach
meiner ansicht stärken indem er klar
zwischen den begriffen art und
lebensformen unterscheiden würde
innerhalb eines näher zu bestimmten
begrüßt der lebensform könnte ein
standard definiert werden an dem eine
form der normativität hängt dieser
normativ aufgeladenen begriff der
lebensform wäre aber sicher nicht der in
der biologie tradierte griff der
lebensform denn dieser ist viel zu vage
und offen jedem individuum werden in der
biologischen lebensformen lehre auch
nicht nur eine sondern lebensformen zu
beschrieben lebensform wechsel ist die
regel nicht die ausnahme
darauf hatte ich ihn gewesen es muss
also ein neuer begriff der lebensform
sein den thompson einführt ich will
nicht sagen dass dieser keinen sinn
macht aber er sollte zumindest deutlich
sowohl von den biologischen begriff
derart als auch der lebensform
unterschieden werden hier in der
biologie verwendet wird thompsons
lebensformen begriff könnte auch durch
seine biologische verwurzeln
ihr könnt ja durchaus eine biologische
verwurzelung haben wie jeder wissen
könnte der naturführer verwendet in
ihnen ist angegeben wie eine pflanze
oder ein tier aussehen muss wenn es
einer bestimmten art zugeordnet werden
sollen
ich möchte aber bezweifeln dass thompson
lebensform begriff über diesen
pragmatischen kontext der tiere und
pflanzen bestimmungen hinaus eine tiefe
verankerung in modernen biologischen
theorien hat und haben kann
mir scheint als lebensform begriff in
der typologische denken naturgeschichte
des 18ten jahrhundert verankert zu sein
diese hatte für jedes individuum eine
seine artgemäße gottgegebene form
postuliert an der sich zu orientieren
eine norm darstellte für die biologie
seit darwin kann aber nicht eine solche
norm leiten zu sein war nicht die
konstanz einer art oder lebensraum
sondern gerade die variation theoretisch
zentrale ist an der variation der
individuen hängt bekanntlich die ganze
dynamik der evolution
ich komme zu dem dritten abschnitts
normativität und lebendigkeit
der zweite begriff der normativität den
ich untersuchen möchte geht auch von dem
begriff der lebensformen haus allerdings
spielt dabei der erste wortbestandteil
das leben die größere rolle als die form
die normativität soll sich hier direkt
aus der lebendigkeit ergeben
philipp erfurt hat dafür den begriff der
natur des naturgemäß der naturgemäßen
gutheil naturgärten es vorgeschlagen die
naturgemäße gut hyde ist für sie eine
besonderheit der lebewesen weil allein
in bezug auf lebewesen von einem
wohlergehen und der erfüllung von
bedürfnissen die rede sein könne
lebewesen würden daher im gegensatz zu
den unbeliebten dingen über ein
intrinsische gut verfügen
er spricht von einer natürlichen
normativität national activity in bezug
auf lebewesen pflanzen ebenso wie tiere
nettoergebnis er sah die feine tapete
only to loving fing sie beim service
center parcs charakteristik celebrations
ist in trance economies gürtels änderte
die pens directly on relations in die
video-plattform wickies die gut heilt
hängt hier wesentlich am lebens begriff
insofern es zum begriff des lebens dazu
gehört der fünf bezeichnete gestört und
zerstört werden kann
die gut hängt hier aber auch in form
begriff weil dieser über thompson einen
standard für einen bestimmten typus von
lebewesen liefert für die lebensform des
menschen ist es nach ford beispielsweise
charakteristisch das sehen hören
ein gedächtnis und
konzentrationsfähigkeit zu geben zu ihr
gehören daher sei vor dem hintergrund
dieser fähigkeiten das gute des
menschlichen lebens zu bestimmen dieser
verbindung dieser vorschlag diese
vorstellungen die verbindung zwischen
dem lebens begriff und dem guten wert
von normativen kann auf eine reiche
tradition zurückblicken
christina finster spricht von normativen
status aller lebewesen das leben selbst
und nicht erst das medizinische urteil
macht aus dem biologisch normative einen
wert von liam bei hans jonas kann man
lesen etwas von der fundamentalen selbst
besorgtheit
alles leben ist das absolute interesse
des organismus an seinem eigenen dateien
und eben christina prisdorf schreibt das
grundlegende kriterium für moralische
berücksichtigungswürdigen ist die
gedeihen fähigkeit auf der basis dieser
gedeihen fähigkeit könne allen lebewesen
an je eigenes gut sowie darauf folgen
bessere bzw schlechtere zustände
zugeschrieben werden
das problem dieser ansätze sehe ich
darin dass sie mit grund scharfen
begriffen operieren
diese begriffe wie leben selbst
besorgtheit oder gedeihen fähigkeit
bewegen sich auf der grenze von
naturalistischen beschreibung begriffen
und normativen wert begriffen
sie müssen sich auf dieser grenze
bewegen weil sie die beiden an der
grenze zusammenstoßen lager miteinander
vermitteln und die grenze überwinden
wollen die begriffe bleiben dabei aber
nach meinem eindruck zu wenig analysiert
so wie ich sie verstehe liegt diesen
begriffen in naturalistischer hinsicht
nicht als die vorstellung von
kybernetischen sollwerten zu gründen
es geht darum dass organisches streben
nach selbsterhaltung als normativ
relevant auszuzeichnen
ich habe demgegenüber stark bezweifle
ich sehe nicht warum etwas das auch
seine selbsterhaltung hin angelegte
stabilisiert ist intrinsisch gut ist
zurecht bekämpfen wir viele auf ihre
selbsterhaltung angelegte lebewesen wie
den pesterreger oder computer wären
streben nach selbsterhaltung oder
gedeihen fähigkeit ist daneben ein
natural mechanismus denen es auch im
bereich des anorganischen gibt meines
erachtens im bereich von klimaphänomenen
der erde oder anderen planeten
ich denke außerdem dass eine moralische
berücksichtigungswürdigen auch solche
entitäten besteht die nicht leben wie
ökosystemen oder gänzlich an organische
gebilde wie ein stall aktiv ein berg
oder ein natürlicher flusslauf ich halte
also die kriterien der lebendigkeit
selbst gesorgt hat oder gedeihen
fähigkeit weder hinreichend noch
notwendig hinblick auf moralische
berücksichtigungswürdigen und
insbesondere sehe ich eben nicht warum
naturale mechanismen der kinetischen
regulation die diesen begriffen meines
erachten
zugrunde liegen ethische oder in anderer
hinsicht normative implikationen haben
sollen
die über die rede von sollwerten
hinausgeht ethisch relevanten
normativität ergibt sich meines
erachtens nicht automatisch aus der
spezifischen organisations weise oder
kybernetischen reguliert heid von
systemen und sie ergibt sich auch nicht
das sollte der zweite abschnitt zeigen
aus naturhistorischen urteilen die jedes
individuum notwendig zu einem exemplar
seiner gattung machen
ethisch relevanten normativität ergibt
sich erst im sozialen miteinander von
sprachbegabten rationalen wesen aus der
konstellation von faktoren über die die
lebensform dieser wesen charakterisiert
werden kann würde ich den begriff der
normativität entfalten kurzem ihr jetzt
nicht mehr viel zeit bleibt deswegen hat
es nur andeuten
es ist wie gesagt meines erachtens nicht
ein einzelner grund der für die
entstehung von normativität in der
menschlichen lebens form entscheidend
ist sondern eine ganze konstellation von
faktoren
einige faktoren und die mir wichtig
erscheinen habe ich einfach aufgelistet
das sehen sie hier
soziale kooperation contra faktisches
denken imagination fähigkeit proposition
aale sprache argumentation mit nicht
beobachtbaren entitäten denken in
analogie in relationen und abstrakten
regeln überlegung sphe ich kite
nationalitäten leben in einem raum von
gründen
reflektierende selbstbewertung für of
mind empathie zwecksetzung autonomie
anders handeln können und selbst und
fremd verpflichtung versprechens und
volkskultur wie man dass man schluss an
ernst tugendhat nennen könnte der ja
meint die menschen seien diejenigen
tiere die sich vorwürfe machen können
das ist eine reihe von schlagwörtern die
mit protagonisten der jüngeren
philosophie geschichte verbunden sind
wie die faktoren zusammenhängen müsste
im einzelnen geprüft werden
ich will nur auf die ersten beiden
faktoren etwas näher eingehen die
soziale kooperation und die imagination
fähigkeit beide hängen eng zusammen
denn das verstehen der mentalen zustände
von anderen ist eine form der
imagination fähigkeit
und gleichzeitig für soziale kooperation
entscheidend in seinem vor einigen
jahren erschienenen buch wird gab
deutsch der unterschied bringt der
psychologe thomas kubendorff diese
beiden fähigkeiten zu sammeln
die zwei beine mit denen wir im bild von
sorten drauf die spalte von der natur in
die kultur oder von den anderen tieren
zu den menschen überschreiten sind
unsere fähigkeit zur grenzenlosen
imagination und unsere leidenschaft die
köpfe zusammenzustecken also unserer
kooperations drang wie er es nennt
durch diese fähigkeiten verwandelt sich
die kommunikation in proposition aale
begründende sprache das gedächtnis in
mentale zeitreisen soziale kognition
gibt eine theorie of mind problemlösung
in abstraktes denken soziale tradition
in eine kumulative kultur war und
schließlich empathie in moralität sowie
ist im dorf das darstellt nachdem der
schritt über die kluft getan hast
verfügt der mensch über eine andere
lebensform als andere lebewesen
er hört auf ein tier zu sein wie es in
der inzwischen überholten
begrifflichkeit der wissen die 80er
jahre gültigen abendländischen tradition
einmal hieß in dieser sprachlichen
unsicherheit ob der mensch nun als ein
tier wie jedes andere als ein anderes
tier oder als kein tier bezeichnet
werden sollte
drückt sich meines erachtens die
stellung der kategorie mensch zwischen
lebensform und begriffe aus und darauf
komme ich jetzt ganz am ende als spezies
ist der mensch ein tier ein kleiner arzt
im großen baum der tiere an die maglia
wesentlich verschiedenen von den tieren
kann der mensch verständnis als
biologische art schon deshalb nicht sein
weil arten keine wesentlichen
intrinsischen eigenschaften haben mit
john gray und jon hawkins sehen sich
gezeigt haben
biologische arten haben nur relationale
eigenschaften der mensch kann seine
nationalität und sprache und mit ihr die
dimension der normativität verlieren
aber er könnte doch die gleiche art
bleiben als lebensform ist der mensch
dagegen kein tier sondern durch einen
komplex von intrinsischen eigenschaften
und fähigkeiten gekennzeichnet die seine
welt von der arbeitsweise der tiere
radikal unterscheidet trotzdem ist der
spezi spezies begriff für uns von
bedeutung
auch von ethischer bedeutung wir halten
ihn aufrecht nicht zuletzt aufgrund von
historischen erfahrungen der ausgrenzung
wir hatten ihn aufrecht weil er
inklusive ist weil er auch solche wesen
einschließt die nicht über die genannten
fähigkeiten verfügen die zumindest nicht
aktiv an der aufrechterhaltung der
menschlichen lebens form beteiligt sind
die säuglinge schlafende oder geistig
schwer kranke menschen
auch ihnen schreiben wie eine würde zu
und auch sie fassen wir
selbstverständlich als menschen auf in
der unterscheidung von mensch als art
und lebensform begriff liegt eine
trennung des kriteriums zur definition
der kategorie mensch also des kriteriums
zur identifikation eines wesens als
mensch von der extra nativen ebene die
zentrale explorative begriffe benennt
über die das wesen dieser art die natur
des menschen wenn man so sagen will
ausgezeichnet werden kann wie sprache
rationalität und so weiter ausgehend von
biologisch von biologischen art begriff
macht die rede von der natur des
menschen keinen sinn siebte station als
lebensform kann sie aber expliziert
werden sprache rationalität normativität
gehören zudem dass die menschliche
lebensform besonders macht
auch wenn nicht auch wenn nicht jeder
mensch sprachfähig oder rational ist
hier zeigt sich also der wert der
unterscheidung von art und lebensform
begriff normativität ist eine dimension
die ausgehend von einer lebensform nicht
ausgehend von biologischen speziell
entwickelt werden kann
über normativität kann in den
lebensformen charakterisiert werden die
auch in anderen spezies als der
menschlichen verwirklicht wird
normativität könnte als eine
exploratorische wichtiger begriff
verstanden werden
die definiert was die menschliche
lebensform ist und aus dem andere
eigenschaften dieser lebensform
verständlich also extra tief basar quasi
der über damit gerade nicht definieren
kann was ein mensch ist die menge der
derjenigen die über sprache rationalität
und normativität verfügen die also der
lebensform des menschen angehören deckt
sich zwar nicht mit der menge der
menschen verstanden als angehörige des
pcs homo sapiens allein die angehörigen
der lebensform mensch definieren aber
wie relevant die zugehörigkeit zur
biologischen spezies für ihre moralische
berücksichtigungsfähig kyte ist unsere
historische erfahrung zeigt dass sie
sehr relevant sein sollte dies ist aber
eben eine historische erfahrung die an
den naturalismus stark macht den
naturalismus der verwandtschaft dies ist
kein abriss argument vielen dank